dans quelques instants on appellera la
grand mère mais auparavant un petit but
à but spécial enfants pourquoi enfants
parce que c'est la fête mais parce que
y'a jean-michel surtout on est en train
de me dire plutôt que de faire une
transition qui de toute façon n'aboutira
pas faisons entrer celui qui a perdu il
ya quelques instants le jeu je viens de
compter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces 30 à ces jeux vous ainsi au départ
je les cuisine j'ai donné un mois dans
les déguisements je dis c'est pas sympa
je sais pas si j'aimerais être à sa
place ou pas mais je ne regrette pas une
seule image et ses deux filles que vous
me disiez à nos deux invités qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
oui au moins merci camille ya qu un truc
qui me fait cesser la barre balana plus
que